AGAINST THE TRUMP MACHINE AND
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
SO FAR DEMOCRATS SEEM TO HAVE
LEARNED NOTHING FROM THEIR
FUTILE BATTLE AGAINST THE BRETT
KAVANAUGH NOMINATION.
THEY PUT THE COUNTRY THROUGH
THREE WEEKS OF WHAT BASICALLY
AMOUNTED TO A HE SAID, SHE SAID.
>> I THOUGHT THAT BRETT WAS
ACCIDENTALLY GOING TO KILL ME.
>> Judge Kavanaugh: I HAVE
NEVER DONE THIS TO HER OR
ANYONE.
>> Laura: THE USE PAID
ACTIVIST TO CORNER SENATORS.
>> YOU ARE ALLOWING SOMEONE WHO
IS UNWILLING TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR HIS OWN
ACTIONS TO SIT IN THE HIGHEST
COURT OF THE COUNTRY.
>> >> Laura: THEY HELD A PROTET
THAT RANGED FROM IN    ON HINGED
THAT RANGED FROM IN    ON HINGET
THAT RANGED FROM IN    ON HINGEO
DOWNRIGHT PATHETIC.
>> WE ARE ABOUT TO MARCH!
WE NEED EVERYONE TO PAY
ATTENTION.
>> Laura: I'M NOT PAYING
CAN SHE LEARN SOME RHYMES EVERY
NOW AND THEN?
THEY USE THEIR PALS IN THE PRESS
TO RUN WITH THE MOST OUTLANDISH
SUBSTANTIATED CLAIMS POSSIBLE.
>> BRETT KAVANAUGH PLUNGES
DEEPER INTO DANGER TONIGHT OVER
NAVIGATION OF SEXUAL ASSAULT THE
LEAVES HIS CONFIRMATION IN
MORTAL JEOPARDY.
>> THE THIRD ALLEGATION OF --
AND THE LATE-BREAKING NEWS OF A
FOURTH ACCUSER.
>> SHE CONSIDERS HIS OWN
MEMORIES CREDIBLE AND SHE FELT
IT WAS IMPORTANT THAT SHE TELL
HER STORY BEFORE OTHERS DID
WITHOUT HER CONSENT.
>> Laura: DESPITE ALL THEIR
EFFORTS, THE EMOTIONAL PLEAS AND
ALL THE BIG MONEY BEHIND THEIR
SMEARS, ON SATURDAY AFTERNOON,
KAVANAUGH WAS CONFIRMED BY THE
U.S. SENATE.
SO AFTER THEIR SPECTACULAR
FLAMEOUT, ONE OF THE
DEMOCRATS -- WHAT DO THE
DEMOCRATS DO IN RESPONSE?
THEY DOUBLE DOWN ON FAILURE.
>> IF HE IS ON THE SUPREME COURT
AND THE SENATE HADN'T
INVESTIGATED, THEN THE HOUSE
WILL HAVE TWO.
>> YOU WILL INVESTIGATE?
>> WE WOULD HAVE TO INVESTIGATE
ANY CREDIBLE ALLEGATIONS.
>> I'M TOTALLY FOCUSED WITH ALL
THE ANGRY WOMAN AND THE MEN WHO
LISTENED TO WOMEN AND SUPPORT
THE CREDIBLE ACCOUNTS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT WHICH IS A VERY
UNDERREPORTED, BUT I'M FOCUSED
ON THE LASER BEAM ABOUT THE
ELECTIONS.
>> THERE ARE SIGNS THAT THIS
ANGRY GENDER POLITICS GAME IS
NOT WORKING.
A A MARIST POLL LAST WEEK FOUND
THAT THERE WAS VIRTUALLY NO
VENDOR GAP WHEN IT COMES TO
JUSTICE BRETT KAVANAUGH.
AMONG EITHER REPUBLICANS OR
DEMOCRATS.
80% OF REPUBLICAN WOMEN HAVE A
FAVORABLE VIEW OF KAVANAUGH WITH
81% OF REPUBLICAN MEN AGREEING.
THEN MEN HAVE A GREATER
UNFAVORABLE VIEW OF KAVANAUGH,
85%, TO 75% OF WOMEN.
THE STRUGGLE OVER KAVANAUGH AS
WE NOTED IN THE ANKLE SHORTLY
AFTER HE WAS NOMINATED WAS
ALWAYS GOING TO BE POLITICAL.
THE DEMOCRATS WERE GOING TO
SAVAGE ANYONE DONALD TRUMP NOT
KNOW MIKE NOMINATED EXCEPT
MAYBE, IF HE RENOMINATED SOMEONE
LIKE MARY GARLAND OR SOMEONE
COMPLETELY CUCKOO LIKE THAT.
THE PERPETUAL RAGE AGAINST ALL
THINGS TRUMP ALSO SEEMS TO
INTENSIFY THE MORE TRUMP
ACCOMPLISHES.
AND IT'S UNRELATED BY THE WAY TO
HOW OPTIMISTIC AND HOW CONFIDENT
AMERICAN WORKERS AND CONSUMERS
ARE ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
NONE OF THAT EVEN MATTERS TO THE
CRAZIES ON THE LEFT.
CONSIDER WHAT THE PRESIDENT,
WITH THE HELP OF MITCH
McCONNELL, HAS ACCOMPLISHED
JUST ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE OF JUDICIAL NOMINATIONS?
OF COURSE, TO SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES, 26 FEDERAL APPELLATE
COURT JUSTICES, AND 41 FEDERAL
DISTRICT COURT JUDGES.
AND BY THE WAY, THEY ARE JUST
GETTING STARTED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS CHALKED UP
SO MANY OTHER IMPRESSIVE WINS
AND GETS VERY LITTLE CREDIT IN
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA FOR IT.
HE SUCCESSFULLY RENEGOTIATED
NAFTA, FORCING BOTH MEXICO AND
CANADA TO ACCEPT A DEAL THAT
FINALLY BEGINS TO TREAT AMERICAN
MANUFACTURERS AND AMERICAN
WORKERS FAIRLY.
HE IS A ROLLBACK NEEDLESS
GOVERNMENT REGULATIONS.
BY THE WAY, FOR EVERY NEW
REGULATION, THE TRUMP FEDERAL
AGENCY, THEY BASICALLY RESCINDED
22.
THE GOVERNMENT ESTIMATES THAT
THE IN LIFETIME NET COST SAVINGS
OF HIS DEREGULATORY EFFORTS IS
ABOUT $8.1 BILLION.
[CHANTING]
>> Laura: CAN'T PASS THE
LARGEST TAX CUT IN A GENERATION,
MANUFACTURING JOBS ARE BACK, THE
GDP IS ABOVE 4% AND WE HAVE THE
LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT IN NEARLY 50
YEARS.
TRUMP IS TAKING ON CHINA FOR
THEIR YEARS OF CHEATING AND
STEALING FROM THE AMERICAN
WORKERS AND AMERICAN BUSINESSES.
FINALLY, WE HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT RECOGNIZES
THE THREAT THAT THIS EXPANSIVE
COMP COMIC COMMUNIST REGIME
POSES TO OUR OWN NATIONAL AND
ECONOMIC SECURITY.
TRUMP IS TRANSFORMING BOTH THE
COUNTRY AND THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
AND NOT A MOMENT TOO SOON.
EVEN THE RANKS OF SOME OF THE
NEVER-TRUMPERS HAVE DWINDLED AND
THEY COULD BE BEGRUDGINGLY ADMIT
THE GENIUS OF DONALD TRUMP.
THE KAVANAUGH WAS A CLARIFYING
MOMENT FOR THE NEVER-TRUMPER
CROWD, LIKE A POLITICAL
ASTRINGENT.
BRETT STEVENS, HUGH HEWITT AND
ERICK ERICKSON ALL LINED UP
BEHIND HIM IN THE FIGHT.
BY THE WAY, REMEMBER, THIS WAS
ERICK ERICKSON WHO WAS HEAD OF
THAT RED STATE WEBSITE BACK IN
AUGUST OF 2015.
>> I WANTED TO GIVE THE MAN A
LOT OF LATITUDE BECAUSE I KNOW
HE TAPS INTO SOME ANGER THAT
EVEN I SHARE WITH THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, AND A LOT OF US HERE DO.
BUT IF OUR STANDARD-BEARER HAS
TO RESORT TO THAT, WE NEED A NEW
STANDARD-BEARER.
>> AND THIS IS ERIC ERICKSON TO
THE "WASHINGTON EXAMINER" LAST
WEEK."
FOR THE FIRST TIME I SEE MYSELF
VOTING FOR TRUMP IN 2,020.
IT HAS A LOT TO DO WITH
KAVANAUGH.
HE'S NOT THE ONLY REASON BUT HE
IS DEFINITELY THE STRAW THAT
BROKE THE CAMEL'S BACK.
IT IS ERIC CALLING HIMSELF A
CAMEL OR IS THAT THE LEFT?
ANYWAY, I'M HAPPY, I'M GLAD.
ERIC IS A GOOD GUY.
OF COURSE ESTABLISHMENT FIGURES
SUCH AS LINDSAY GRAHAM AND
McCONNELL, NONE OF THOSE GUYS
WANTED TRUMP TO BE THE NOMINEE.
THEY'VE ALL REALLY STEPPED UP
HELPING TO PUSH KAVANAUGH OVER
THE CONFIRMATION FINISH LINE.
MAYBE THEY ARE CLOSER, ALL OF
THEM COME UP TO RECOGNIZING THAT
THE TIME IS UP ON THE OLD G.O.P.
AND IT TRUMP'S POLICIES ARE
ACTUALLY BEARING FRUIT.
ALL THE EXCITEMENT IS WITH
TRUMP, LET'S FACE IT.
ALL THE MOMENTUM IS WITH HIS
IDEAS.
THERE IS TOO MUCH ON THE LINE
FOR INTRAPARTY SQUABBLES ANY
LONGER.
THE CHOICE FOR VOTERS IS NOW
REALLY SIMPLE.
MOB RULE, OR THE RULE OF LAW.
PERPETUAL RAGE, OR REAL RESULTS?
DEMONIZATION, OR DUE PROCESS?
AS AN EXAMPLE, THIS IS WHAT THE
ANTI-TRUMP RAGE MACHINE WAS UP
TO OVER THE WEEKEND.
PROTESTERS IN PORTLAND BLOCKED A
MAJOR THOROUGHFARE CAUSING
NEEDLESS DISRUPTIONS.
WHEN A DRIVER DARED TO PUSH
THROUGH THE BLOCKADE, THIS WAS
THE REACTION OF THESE
OPEN-MINDED AND TOLERANT
LEFTISTS.
[SCREAMING AND YELLING]
>> Laura: IT'S LIKE A SCENE
FROM HOMELAND OR SOMETHING FROM
BENGHAZI.
THE FAR LEFT, LET'S FACE IT, IS
NOW RUNNING THE DEMOCRATIC
ASYLUM.
>> President Trump: OF THE
MAIN BASE OF THE DEMOCRATS HAS
SHIFTED SO FAR LEFT THAT WE WILL
END UP    UP AND VENEZUELA.
THIS COUNTRY WILL END UP BEING
VENEZUELA.
I THINK A LOT OF DEMOCRATS WILL
BE VOTING.
>> Laura: TONIGHT I FELT VERY
PRIVILEGED TO BE IN ATTENDANCE
AS FORMER JUSTICE ANTHONY
KENNEDY SWORE IN OUR NEW JUSTICE
OF THE SUPREME COURT, MY FRIEND
OF MANY, MANY YEARS AND ONE OF
AMERICA'S FINEST LEGAL MINDS,
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
>> IS ASSOCIATE JUSTICE OF THE
SUPREME COURT OF UNITED STATES,
AS ASSOCIATE JUSTICE OF THE
SUPREME COURT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION AND LAWS
OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> UNDER THE CONSTITUTION AND
LAWS OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> ALSO HELP ME GOD.
>> SO HELP ME GOD.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: IF YOU COULD FEEL
THE EXCITEMENT IN THAT ROOM AND
IT WAS AMAZING.
ONE OF THE MOST AMAZING LOCAL
MOMENTS I'VE BEEN PRIVILEGED TO
OBSERVE.
MEANWHILE THE HATERS ON THE LEFT
ARE SQUARING RETRIBUTION AND
PROMISING MORE MAYHEM.
>> SO I SAY WHEN THEY GO LOW, WE
HIT HARDER.
>> IS YOUR MIND MADE UP?
[YELLING]
>> Laura: THEY ARE FOR WOMEN,
RIGHT?
WOMEN CAN BE ANYTHING THEY WANT
TO BE OR THINK WHATEVER THEY
WANT TO THINK?